I feel like this is me fighting against
evil you're not gonna lose to a wig
chicken wing
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody prefers to
be feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even had her wings and at
long last I'm joined by Hannibal Buress
he's one of the best stand-ups in the
game you know him from as many films and
TV shows like broad city in the Eric
Andre show you can also catch him on his
podcast they handsome Rambler Hannibal
welcome to the show thanks man
appreciate it how are you with hot food
I like some spice but I don't think food
should make you uncomfortable right
right all-purpose accidentally at best
this is our hundredth episode I can't
believe I'm still standing
Hannibal we've been trying to get you in
this seat forever ever since I
bum-rushed you on the street in New
Orleans last year yeah remember that
I'll start weak in New Orleans we'll get
that done that was a good time good
party yeah all right you ready get it
going I was doing
[Music]
yes - yes normal mm-hmm who's I the
flavor is flavorant Bishop so last year
you moved from New York back home to
Chicago explaining to Stephen Colbert
it's less famous people for competition
so if you'll humor me I want to get a
handle burr a city guide from hahahahaha
do you [ __ ] with Garrett's caramel and
cheddar popcorn or no I only have that
as a gift well I think Conan has it back
stays it is so that's when I have
Garrett's it's great but I don't really
go get popcorn out I don't go out of my
way for like that what do you think is
the better nickname the Windy City here
the second city Windy City oh just a
shine so yeah but I don't like sexy as a
name there's a great comedy theater but
now tonight how do you describe juke
music to people who don't know what it
is who's i hanging out with I was
hanging out with a friend there wasn't
from Chicago I played some Joop stuff
and he was vibing to it and as a song
went on he said are they just gonna keep
saying the same [ __ ] over and over you
know a fast-paced beat with somebody
saying some phrase i mode add the other
boat oh [ __ ] look at that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] got on case with oh it's just a
second so it was so funny to hear an
outsider's perspective wait like they
say they just don't say that it made me
laugh so hard oh yeah
that's how you explain
all right so this next one is Louisiana
a classic all right yeah I know this
familiar not for regular life yeah I
watch the show in season but that's the
only one I was just like you know it
makes me feel comfortable so when it
comes to your TV career you have a
pretty insane track record when it comes
to showing up on some of the funniest
shows on television which set was the
most fun to be on the Eric Andre said is
pretty fun cuz you don't really know
what's gonna happen and [ __ ] like the
the most fun I think I had was the rapid
warrior ninja with Danny Brown Danny
brass at rocky hey Sam oh my go go
Dreamer
we would just die because you know the
course was set up nobody really ran
through it and I was watching yo they
might get hurt Danny took a nasty fall
in there
and then you got that shot of him
looking real crazy and then too I
actually talked to Danny about his
appearance there and he said that he was
being kind of an [ __ ] about it before
you guys started filming that's fair
yeah absolutely
[ __ ] look crazy I would have been our
question that too - you know y'all said
you hear it's well when I got here early
I like that by the way I got here like
11 18 which is too early it's like the
weird early 45 minutes you know what I
mean you're gonna beat me here so I
would walk around a little bit
it's not a good walking area but I walk
to the main block block away
Raphael therapy place I did cryotherapy
kill some time you did before the show
yeah not very weird to do cryotherapy
right before eating a bunch of hot sauce
it helped
I think I would support a weird amount
of hot sauce on it was a little bit of a
clumsy poor Hannibal's like that poor
all right yeah I got some kick
I like that do you think that Versace
breakfast is your most underrated verse
[Music]
what think a lot of people do about
Vasanti breakfast not enough people know
size your breakfast you want to know the
story right yeah I do I hate this all
the gibberish rap song and got really
excited about it and put it out a couple
blogs picked it up and then I was I was
hyped and I just told people I say hey
send me a beat I'll do some features I
was I would do a bunch of features you
know I think it was Freddie Scott he set
up the studio and then I just went and
did a few verses and then nothing else
after that just stopped and then
throughout your career you've
consciously mixed comedy and rap in
interesting ways but I'm wondering when
you look at a rapper who's the rapper
that makes you laugh
Danny Browns funny t-pain is hilarious
t-pain is a character man how hug I
would have in Atlanta a few times and
it's gone it's gone poorly did he take
you to this strip club
it's only the strip club always goes a
strip club and then it's just when you
could pour your own drinks that's when
the trouble happens
when you pour in your own drinks that's
when it Estlin has to begin in a
disaster there's a salad
straightforward sauce that's what we
were going for Hannibal the highest of
compliments I appreciate that yeah so
never I hear a comedian talk about
getting their start and sometimes we'll
have sort of a dark quality to it you
know playing laundromats in front of 12
people or living in their cars or maybe
sleeping on the subway or outside of a
Starbucks and I wonder if you look back
on the road when did you feel furthest
from success
turn those time that they were it didn't
feel that dark then you know what I mean
cuz it was I was just trying to keep
your head above water I was 23
we still had youthful ambition and
energy and [ __ ] where if I was going
through the same she had 35 I'd be like
yo you're mine [ __ ] sleeping in
Starbucks I'm 35 23 you're not out in
the star that's in that time where it
was just cuz I knew what I was trying to
trying to do do you remember the first
time you got really heckled sometimes
you bombed out of place the others cut
the music on on you Bobby there's no
warning but something's gonna fade in
I've had a kid kind of slow fate I'm
gonna stay - hey what's that what is
that shut that [ __ ] off
so getting the music just played on you
in a bit in the middle of what you think
is a great idea somebody not let's just
uh do some music on that and use this
moment to transition to the rest of the
show have you ever invited a girl to a
show that you're into yeah bombed in
front of her early on yeah what's that
like I don't know I don't even know if I
was bringing her just press well I was
just bringing her to hang out but yeah
we didn't see each other after that I
don't know if maybe we both got busy or
maybe it was that who knows but yeah it
didn't help
ghost pepper or ask that again I want to
see now you know what I feel it now this
was a slope
some of them creep on you is a slow bar
right here mmm-hmm all right Hannibal we
have a current segment on our show
called explain that Graham where do a
deep dive on our guest Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context okay so I'll bust out the laptop
I'll show you the picture and then I
just tell me the bigger story does that
sound good
all right explain that Graham Campos too
much crazy stuff on the ground you know
you don't you don't so I'm wondering
what you gonna have but it doesn't have
to be crazy
no just let me be interesting okay like
here we're not Dave Chappelle that was
uh he had just set a record for selling
tick as a son I just thought I'd be a
funny photo shoot I forget the name of
the venue but they was wherever the
shows were in Montreal yeah and I had
got a show in Montreal and I did
appreciate that he sold more tickets
dude yeah all right Hannibal up next
football throwback high school football
throwback yeah that's died Matt sound
that I was with streaks yeah Steinmeier
streaks I didn't get that much playing
time a lot of people said that in the
comments they'll you look like you
didn't get any plans and I was like damn
it did right got it
oh yeah I was uh
they had me playing tight in I didn't
get many reps it Oh at least once or
twice when they finally put me in I had
false start
we were already lose it I get right in
the game five-yard penalty
then next play get pulled over by the
defensive end sacks the quarterback I'm
just
yeah it was you know it's a learning
phase I had to go in the Gettys for this
one but can you explain that jumpsuit
haha I think you busted this out on
multiple occasions like you've hit a red
carpet with this thing do you have just
the one
do you have a bunch in your closet no I
just got that one I've busted yeah I see
that's the thing with my I'm not one of
those but if I've been seen in it ain't
wearing it again now they got rocked it
on Seth show Steph Meyers show brought
to that the secret life of pets for me
I'm gonna check it out I'll wear it into
the daddy's home from beer I had it all
in the SUV I was running a little late
to the carpet you know like am i right
to him I rocked a jumpsuit and then I
didn't know if the carpet was gonna be
done so I didn't want to just hit the
carpet in the jumpsuit and then
everybody already went inside so I was
like I was probably so I'm running late
you're probably done and [ __ ] and so I
had just in case I had some separate
[ __ ] in the car so I switched it to just
jeans and some regular [ __ ] and left a
jumpsuit so yeah man it's a lot that
goes into it
[Laughter]
[Music]
get that one that was something huh
mm-hmm
what what so local Jolokia scorpion yeah
five percent of profits go to charity I
did this random thing where I was high
and I take an adderall I was just on the
internet I came across some tweet about
this girl she want to go to wrestling
school and then I was just in a good
mood and it was a couple grand I'm like
sure I've seen her stranger to rest in
the school and I told the story all
Rogen's show and then I'm just telling
it just as a as a story you know little
podcast anecdote yeah but then I get a
bunch of messages like hey I heard you
sent that person of rezulin I'm trying
to go to med school
oh I'm trying to start this type of
business can you help my merch company
it was the weirdest [ __ ] and I just add
it to it yeah yeah I just [ __ ] up cuz
now people gonna do it and then people
gonna do it ingests awesome as a joke as
a joke well speaking of podcast I want
to take it back to the handsome Rambler
podcast on this one cuz as I understand
it you met your co-host DJ Tony trim at
Southern Illinois University Carbondale
right knowledge yeah and then that's
where the comedy bug bit you right yes I
went with my friend GD and he was doing
stand-up I went and watched him GD was
really funny with some other people but
it's open mic so all the mics that's
what they're for
so what kind of demystified it for me
well I didn't you know I was used to
seeing polished stand-up on television
and just I can try to head out it's
available to me um you know I like
performing and [ __ ] so let me try this
out I tried it it was some stuff that I
was weirdly aggravated about and I just
wrote him down ahead no outlet for just
simple [ __ ] why is the spelling bee on
ESPN that's not a sport just simple old
man grumpy
[Applause]
[Music]
when you got you got a little rope on up
yeah how much do you think the bottle in
effects how well it sells you know I
think that hot sauce it's like wine
where people I think buy with their eyes
more than anything else you know yeah
just find a label that they like or
whatever or they feel like threatened or
dared buy it you know look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ] got a goddamn bullet you get a
keychain with it they're really pushing
it there what's this in a store I think
that's like 19 bucks or something like
that sorry we skipped ahead my bad no
that's okay get on the auto-tune it's on
your youtube channel used to review
restaurants on your pit stops along the
way notably you called Cracker Barrel
the Tim Duncan of restaurants a
superstar but slightly boring do you
still stand by your review of lambs
Creek in Mansfield Pennsylvania which
you called a real piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it was a I haven't been back you know I
might have written a review or done that
that review in it you know in a heated
state and it was a little bit bad though
yeah it was just one full celery stalk I
had seen anything like that you know
some stuff is just really visually
jarring mm-hmm it was just one of those
things well doesn't gotta get that out
of it it's terrible
just tastes like poison yeah just a
strong mm-hmm like hey you want to make
some terrible Mason put a little this on
there you can ruin your whole meal I
don't believe in those I was gonna say I
don't feel like you have to be a
superhero but I'd be on a superhero
you're in it it's just committee I feel
I just me fighting against evil
I could lose to a wig chicken wing
ah yeah man
so know that you're a huge UFC Fan I see
your ringside with Zac Efron and I know
that you're even sponsoring fighters for
a while there yes my trying to spawn so
a fighter you have a favorite fighter
Yair Rodriguez is pretty entertaining
well he got beat up recently but he's a
very exciting fighter Dom you just
standing by with the with the refills
come on in come on in
I
if you could pair any two comedians for
a UFC pay-per-view event which to would
you match up and why well you got to get
Rogen in there because he can actually
fight Rogen gotta do one of those
matches waiting go against three people
John Mulaney
my cup size and shucky ducky against Joe
Rogan live at the MGM Grand Arena get
your tickets yeah that'd be great
all right so this next one is mad dog
357 with number 9 plutonium what the
[ __ ]
you ain't gonna follow up he's gonna say
so addition shown iam essentially and
then just move along and I just eat
if someone who's done this show a
hundred times I've come to the point
where I kind of don't want to know like
I don't really want to know how the
sausage is made if I give this product
as a gift I will make the recipient
fully aware of the potential danger if
used or handled improperly here by this
claim release and relinquish any and all
claims accident lawsuits that I or any
of my dependents areas family members or
legal representatives may have it is
[ __ ] up mm-hm
all right
I'm trying to eat in a different way to
wear that [ __ ] don't touch my tongue
being strategic trying to be strategic
we own us so as someone whose work spans
blockbuster cameos and Baywatch - gonzo
live shows with Eric Andre can you break
down the field guide to the Hannibal
Buress fan I have is a for the girl in
the early 20s bra city college age
person kind of you know probably Eric
Andre president I some do like 4550 with
kids daddy's home some people just yell
out they call me Lincoln for Brad city
and it took me a while to be like eight
us that's not my name
Tom do we have any more milk
ah oh yeah I didn't even you got that
picture right there I don't even notice
here the whole time here the whole time
like an oasis
all right Hannibal oh man
so this is the last dab we call it the
last dab because it's tradition around
here to put a little extra on the last
wing you don't have to if you don't want
to you don't have to if you don't want
to isn't that so it's clear already the
qualifies a koala face that's good yeah
that's good oh you know it's a real
roller coaster I'm the third one you're
like oh I could use some more I could
use some more and then you get to the
tent and it's like here we are yeah it
feels put away a lot of milk Hannibal
yeah that's more milk than I don't drink
milk like that yeah so Hema Street
situation going in alright cheers my man
Cheers
all right
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah I went to Ross's right before I
justify this from Ross's but you never
know what to expect some activated
vegetable charcoal hmm alleviate
uncomfortable gas during digestion and
natural vegetable cleanse you know I
even know they sell vitamins I went in
to buy a dollar certain some sunglasses
so there's an impulse buy opposable
weird vitamins you impulse buy [ __ ]
sometimes some all the time I'm a sucker
for that [ __ ] anything they put by the
register I'm just stacking that up all
right Hannibal here we are at the finish
line as we've discussed today there are
many sides to Hannibal comedian/actor
stand out for the Steinmetz streaks but
as anyone who listens to your podcast
knows your secret talent is really in
the art of the Freestyle and as we often
times do on wing 10 we ask way too much
of our guests here we are overreaching
can you hit us with a couple of bars
about how you're feeling right now your
experience that the sauces are the wings
face-filling numb this sauce sucks
tastes like poison what the [ __ ] I might
pass out but I took some pepto-bismol
preemptively get with me this [ __ ] got
me one to sing in a symphony
I was later somebody else can take a
[ __ ] for me from me Hannibal Buress
clear and wings hitting us with the
Freestyle taken out at least 3/4 full
glasses of milk so impressive from this
side of the table and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you Hannibal Buress this
camera this camera or this camera lets
people know what you have going on in
your life I don't I don't have much
going on check me out on tour get my
tour days Hannibal Burres calm slash
tour check out the podcast handsome
Rambler co-hosted by Tony trim the movie
tag coming out June 15th
in theatres yeah thanks episode there
you do feel different though it just it
does shift your move the last couple
questions I guess I hear myself no I
don't talk like this I'm talking totally
different right now hey what's going on
hot ones fans and Sean Evans checking in
if you enjoyed the video do us a solid
please subscribe we're not above begging
for clout over here so you know what to
do smash that subscribe button with a
sledgehammer
who appreciates you me